my guest tonight is a tony and
emmy award-winning actor comedian uh he
is a legend
he is the very best in this business we
call show please welcome
uh my very good friend mr martin short
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
my goodness conan i have not seen you
since the capitol riots
did you ever return nancy pelosi's
statement
i got worked up i was waiting out i
didn't know what we were doing and i
took it i'm
so excited to be here yeah fantastic
you know we are really truly great great
friends
we are and we we share so many things
we're both irish yes
catholic yep uh morning drinkers you
know
you look fantastic well thank you very
much martin
you look like someone freeze-dried
prince harry
because there's a lot of pressure i
would take that i would take that right
now
you look because listen there's a lot of
pressure to stay looking good as you
know
how does it feel to have buckled i just
didn't no
no you look you look great those
freckles are benign right yes
no you're pale you are pale you have to
you look like the human embodiment of
utah you know
you work for me what are you doing
no really unfair you always get the
drums
if you bleached bleach
like something like something that would
appear the the baseboard of ebenezer
scrooge's bed
[Laughter]
no you look fantastic and i'm excited to
be here at
eight let more shows you know and who's
your final guest i'm assuming it's jay
leno
what did i do nothing
if i've done something wrong i'm going
to be upset
[Applause]
i keep calling him and uh he won't come
he doesn't answer
someone is always like he's not here
right now
[Laughter]
so no inspection yeah yeah no really
congrats
28 years yeah yeah
28 years or as matt gates would call it
11 years too old
i don't know what oh no i mean yes and
i'm assuming you're going to go
along grow a long beard like letterman
be the tallest member of zz top you know
i
i was thinking about all the people that
i would most want to have
as we sort of wrap things up here in the
nightly format your name came to mind
and i kept thinking of others but uh
they weren't available but i
but uh but no uh mr martin short there's
no one
uh who uh i i can think of who means
more to me
uh in the world of comedy you are the
consummate professional and i
we've become good friends and i'm so
grateful that you could be here we've
had some good memories
you've made some incredible appearances
on my show
this is my 26th appearance with you is
that true
yes starting back to the old nbc yeah
26
26 two of them i walked through but four
i was gonna say
four were pretty good uh
[Laughter]
what sticks out does anything stick out
to you i mean you've done you do so many
shows
i remember oh i think okay all right
this is hilarious
so this was uh the old show in nbc yep
not the second one the old one
and uh
why why why
i'm just trying to get out the door with
a little dignity
and i bring this leprechaun on
two no no to throw
feces at me this was hilarious so
i i had been the first guest out and you
know kind of killed
and then i moved i moved down the couch
and then
a young actress came out i remember this
but she was like a
model that would had a part not a big
part in a tv movie
yeah but you know that was the guest you
were interviewing so you
you know were and i but i could see you
like this and you were here you
were there and and you're the way it's
angled you remember this andy that
so the the first guest is i mean the the
second guest comes out
marty moves down she's right here she's
talking to me
so no one else can see what i see but i
see
this face and i'm looking at her and i'm
doing the best i can to be
professional and what what you said to
her was
so most of your career now have you been
a model
but now you have a smaller part in a tv
movie
was it was it challenging learning lines
and i go like this
he did that so she's
she's really going to answer that
question
it's 1 20 in the morning
this is my job and and then suddenly i
see this
head peer out and go
and i start to laugh and i bite down
on both sides of my face just to get
through it was hysterical and then at
commercial break
conan gets up bands playing band's
playing he just walks over to me and
says
i'm just trying to make a living [ __ ]
[Laughter]
you did something and i i swear to god
you sent this to me the other day
and what happens is if you do we've done
thousands of hours of this show
and you forget things and
you sent me a video clip and i looked at
it and i had
no memory of it whatsoever but
and i i it just blew my mind it's a time
you came on the show
and uh you showed a clip where you were
made up to look like me
with the great andrea martin it was a
sketch from primetime glick and i was
playing
you yeah uh i can't remember the name
you sent it to me
and imagine you have no idea you're just
living your life
your phone dings i push the video
this is what i see
[Applause]
give me
[Applause]
all right so now i'm like this big goofy
hairy guy
i had no memory of that and then
yeah i texted you back and said i have
this is scaring me i may have it because
i you'd think i'd remember that forever
i have no memory of this and then
immediately you got another text
i sent it to andrea too you sent it to
andrea martin and she wrote back she
said i don't have
one memory of this one is this from sc
tv
i said when we were in sctv conan was in
the ninth grade
yeah it was an all-girls school
uh you have i want to talk about this
you have an up because i'm excited about
it you've been talking about it for a
while and you talk about yourself a lot
it's an upcoming hulu series with uh the
great steve martin
and um it's
and the great and the great selena gomez
selena gomez is on the show
yeah uh and and i know that you you work
a lot with steve martin how's
this project going it's it's it's called
only murders
in the building and it's crossed between
the odd couple and dateline
yeah um no we've been waiting for that
one
it's a murder mystery uh it it drops as
the kids say
um august 31 and uh very much like steve
martin at the urinal
it streams for 36 hours
[Applause]
all right very
selena was so fat you know she
she was very embarrassed the first day
of shooting she made a horrible football
she went up to steve and said i'm such a
big fan judy dench
you know but then they bonded you know
because when steve gets talking about
banjo playing techniques you know we're
all just riveted
here you're going uh i mean you do this
incredible road show obviously
everything had to shut down
uh for the pandemic but you do this
amazing show
which you have guested on which i
guessed it on a highlight for you guys
and it was
uh i have to just insert these things
for the transcript later uh
and um and anyway uh you and steve
martin work together and
just the way you go after steve you go
after each other with insults but it's
absolutely delightful it's one of the
funniest shows i've ever seen oh thank
you
it's great you know steve is endlessly
creative he's always writing
he he never gets any writer's block as
much as we pray for it he doesn't
and he's one of the most sensitive you
know people
you know in the world that you would
meet i mean you you can't
you know it's what's amazing about
stephen this is true and he'd be
embarrassed if i said that
said this but every time we go to a
restaurant
he knows the first name of the waitress
it doesn't matter what restaurant we are
what's amazing is that a he knows their
name and b that they're all named doll
face
so i
steve is one of the funniest guys you
know when i'm before i met steve
i just bring this up because this is how
brilliantly funny and original he's been
his whole life
i remember it was like 1980 i never met
him
and i'm watching television the grammys
and he presents
the best comedy album of
the year and he comes out in full
tuxedo tales and no pants
boxer underwear garters socks
and he doesn't mention it and he just
starts and the nominations are
and he starts reading it and finally a
little
man with a pair of pants comes running
out on a hanger
and steve looks in and says well it's
about time
genius the man's a genius he's a genius
uh i want to congratulate you on a human
note you are
a grandfather and uh this is very
exciting news i mean
oliver's out there oliver's here
where are you wally there you are he
does not want to be seen
oliver wanted to sit as far away from
you as possible
no no i have a a 17 month old a grandson
theodore
and uh ollie and his beautiful wife
alissa are expecting this july their
second son that's exciting and my son
henry is expecting his first son in
september i'll have three
boys under two and it's and it's great
to hear the little
pitter-patter of little feet you know
it's like when david spade comes up
you know we both did our time at starnot
live you of course uh with
much more distinction and fame than i
did i don't know that's true listen i
realized that
going i mean you i i was a cast member
you wrote for it
and you watched it and uh
i mean i used to
no but it is amazing that those i had a
one-year contract and i
and i i kind of regret it
i wish i'd because it made me nervous so
nervous
every every saturday was like a special
and i felt i only
i really i thought i mean you would put
so much work and not just you a couple
of your cohorts would put so much
still it was christopher guest yes and
you would craft these things these
pieces
you came up with a character that uh i
remember when this
character first appeared and it was
seared into everybody's memory anyone
who was interested in comedy
you would create these things that were
so memorable nathan therm
one of the great for my money one of the
great comedy characters of all time
and i was i remember at the time
thinking how do you come up with a
character like that
it was so incredibly original yeah well
i i've told the story before and i'll
tell it again
um but it was amazing because i always
think the characters the best characters
come
from life you know you you pick up your
cleaning and the guy said i couldn't get
the thing
on mr short time now he's not trying to
be a character from serenity live but he
is he's
in dress pants and um so there was a
makeup artist that you're an snl marion
siebert
and she was the most defensive human
being
you had ever met in your life you'd sit
in her chair
and she'd always chain smoke you could
do that inside and maybe
she dab look at me
features don't match this is tough for
me
you're very pale yeah
so um i'd say uh okay well that's fine
so then about a month later christopher
gastner harry sure
and um billy and i were writing uh a
piece satirizing 60 minutes
and i was going to play the defensive
lawyer the lawyer who always represents
the bad guy knows
and we even had a name from nathan thurm
but i didn't know how to do it i didn't
know how to play it
and billy crystal said why don't you do
it as marion seibert
he said you do her behind her back all
the time anyway
and i said no no i'll be caught i'll be
kind of
she won't no they never know so i'd go
down to the set
i got the same brand of cigarettes that
she smoked
but i put a wire down the middle of mine
so as the burn down the ash would never
fall off
yes and i'd go down to the set but i
forget
that marion will be there because she's
the head of makeup
so we start the take i'm nathan thurm
she's over there we both have our
cigarettes harry's playing mike wallace
he's mr
now mr thurm do you feel that was an
appropriate behavior for a lawyer and i
say
i know that you don't think i know that
i'm a lawyer i would know that and the
director goes
cut he's sweating and marian says i know
that you don't think i know that i'm a
[ __ ]
it was insane and then then every time i
did nathan therma i was terrified
i would get caught and i never got
caught until the last
show um her assistant got there was a
big party afterwards their assistant got
drunk and
uh went into her office said marion
do you know that you're nathan's therm
everybody else does
and she was devastated she was so upset
she confronted me
uh at the party and she said i thought
you were my friend
i said marion i am your friend but you
know
impersonation is the highest form of
compliment she said i know that you
don't think i know that
true story this is all true it's jack
farr cruel
i threw a little nixon in there for no
reason yeah and by the way
courtney the kids were that well kids
love my stuff
[Music]
thank you two people uh they're going
right to their phones nixon
what did he do don't clap along
i think you're talking about cynthia
nixon uh marty
who now also goes most which is
confusing
marty i'm told i don't know my staff
keeps these things
secret from me but i'm told that you
have something special
that you wanted to do since this is your
last appearance
on a nightly show that i'm doing it's an
emotional thing for me and
well i got cordoned in two weeks but i
know what you mean
this is a moment for me this is a moment
for me and i'm honestly
all kidding aside you know because i
love to raja
as you i know that's your expression but
um
you are one of the great brilliant
men of our era and i would say you have
influenced
more people in comedy that are
superstars today than
any human being you are adored and
worshiped
and i hope you understand that i don't
i don't i don't but that's very nice
i know you don't agree but i switched
yes yes
and and in all sincerity
may i say that that you are a true
original and i think
an original deserves an original so i
i penned a song just for you and i'd
i'd love to sing it that is if you'd
like me
thank you so much
[Applause]
this is tough for me
there's only you
no one else can ever do
just what you do
if we could only have an hour more
or two you're the best
at what you do who else
can we turn to it breaks my heart
to have to say ado
marty marty yes
can you stop just stop the song for a
minute what's wrong
you don't like the song that i wrote for
you it's a great song
marty i i love the song it's just that
well we happen to have this can you play
a clip
from david letterman's last show
a couple of years ago can you you're the
best at what you do
who else can we turn
there's only you
[Music]
oh thank you very much
well i do it's the exact same side
i hear certain similarities but
letterman is a titan of late night you
should be honored
this song is is for only the very best
the very best okay because you also sang
that song on the last episode
of the magic johnson talk show back in
the late 90s throw the clip
you're
[Applause]
[Music]
there's only
[Music]
well he really had an incredible 11
weeks
it wasn't just late night hosts it's
ridiculous you also sang this song
during the final episode of the jerry
springer show
there's only one day in the biz
and now you're gone
and i am miserably blue
you sang a couple of months ago that
song
when mcdonald's announced they were
discontinuing
the shamrock shape
[Music]
it wasn't easy saying goodbye to that
one i'll tell you
i'm not gonna lie to you i love the song
but you've sung it to many people and a
milkshake
okay well regardless you deserve this
and of all the times i've sung this song
this time i'm on pitch because
there's only ones there only
is there's only one name in this
biz and now you're gone
and i am miserably blue
they're only ones there
[Music]
there's only you
you thank you conan
oh that's right you're still with i'm
alive yes
[Applause]
there's only
thank you baby
we'll be right back